uh good morning everyone and welcome to
nevada's recovery advocacy day
2021. my name is ryan hampton and i'm a
person in long-term recovery
i'm also the organizing director at the
recovery advocacy project
here in las vegas we are so grateful
and we are so thrilled that so many are
joining us here for our virtual
advocacy day on zoom and to everyone
who's joining us on facebook
welcome we're very glad that you're here
before we get started i think it's
critical
that we hold space and recognize the
importance of the work
that every single person on this call
is engaged in now more than ever the
addiction and mental health recovery
communities
need to come together creating
connection and creating community at
scale
due to the devastating impact of covid
this morning is one of the first
opportunities that we have to do
just that the work that we do together
as vaccines are becoming more widely
distributed
and our economy is beginning to open
back up will be a testament to the
resiliency
and the strength of our community our
nation
and our state are on the verge of
another historic high and mortality
rates
due to overdoses and suicide just two
weeks ago the cdc announced for the 12
months
ending in september 2020 close to
90 000 americans lost their lives
due to overdose it goes without saying
that the access to
critical recovery support services the
very
services that saved my own life
must be available to every single
nevadan that seeks them that's the work
that we're focused on
every day at the recovery advocacy
project and on behalf
of our of our entire team we're grateful
for the support
the vision and the passion that so many
of you have offered to our organization
throughout this twin pandemic
together we are committed to giving
people in recovery from
all pathways family members and
supporters of recovery
the grass roots tools to think
and act locally we will continue to work
towards building a visible
and an effective constituency in demand
of community
and public policy based solutions in
response to nevada's
overdose and mental health crisis today
is our opportunity for you to meet your
legislators and leaders in our state
and to create visibility as people who
are the recipients
of nevada's behavioral health systems
and services
you know we've made great strides here
in nevada but we still have so much
further to go
so again thank you for being here the
recovery advocacy project is proud to
help bring this
important day to you albeit virtually
and we look forward to being back
together in person
sooner rather than later i'd now like to
introduce the co
our co-host organization foundation for
recovery
and their executive director sean
o'donnell
thank you ryan it's so great to see
everyone here today
i see many familiar faces and many new
ones i'm sean o'donnell i'm the
executive director of foundation for
recovery
we are nevada's statewide recovery
community organization
a non-profit led and organized by a
diverse network of people
and families in recovery recovery
advocacy day is a statewide call to the
thousands of people in nevada
living in recovery and those impacted by
substance use and mental health
to show up shoulder to shoulder and be
visible as a robust constituency to our
policymakers
each legislative session we organize
around the issues that have directly
impacted our lives housing access to
treatment and health care
justice reform community recovery
supports
record expungement overdose prevention
and syringe access
and so many more it's an opportunity to
speak up about necessary changes to our
behavioral health system
and applaud the work of our legislators
and members of public office who have
helped us move
a little more in the right direction as
ryan had mentioned
we're in a time of record high deaths of
despair
those caused by suicide and drug
overdose
i believe that we are the solution to
our country's long-standing addiction
crisis
for decades those of us with lived
experience have organized mutual aid
networks
to support each other when other
services have been simply inaccessible
it's time that we step into the open as
people in recovery
to share our stories of loss to share
our struggles
to share our stories of being
stigmatized and most
importantly to share our stories of
resilience
triumph and strength addiction
impacts one in three american households
when we mobilize
and step out from behind the shame that
shrouds our connectedness
we help the next person do the same we
begin to normalize the conversation
and make it exponentially easier to
reach and support the next person who is
struggling
as we continue to strengthen our
behavioral health care system
we must also expand recovery support in
our communities
within our workplace our places of
worship
colleges and schools and our everyday
environments
after all we are your neighbors your
family members your students
your employees your customers your
nurses and your teachers
today we'll be joined by some of our
some of your elected officials
you will hear from members of the
community and learn about ways
you can get involved after recovery
advocacy day
i'll close form with a message for
anyone who may be struggling today
or maybe you recently lost someone close
to you
you are not alone you are strong
and you are among a whole community of
people just like you
reaching out to help whenever you need
it
thank you so much to everyone uh for
being here
and with that i'll turn it back over to
you ryan
thank you sean and thank you for the
work that foundation for recovery does
every single day um for for folks all
across this state
it is now my honor to introduce our
first guest this morning and we are
incredibly grateful for him taking time
out of his busy
schedule not to mention right in the
middle of legislative session to join us
today
his presence here with us at recovery
advocacy day shows that leaders
from all across nevada even at the
executive branch
are paying attention to the work you all
do and are committed
to working with the recovery community
as we navigate coming out of these twin
public health crises
covid and the overdose and suicide
crisis
on behalf of all joining our advocacy
day this morning
i'd like to welcome to the virtual stage
our 30th and current governor of the
state of nevada
steve sisselak governor welcome to
recovery advocacy day
thank you ryan i appreciate it uh hello
everyone i am your governor nevada
governor steve sislak
first and foremost i would like to thank
everyone from the foundation for
recovery and the recovery advocacy
project
for inviting me here today with you to
even speak virtually
recovery advocacy day is undoubtedly an
important day
for nevada as it allows individuals and
families
recovering from substance abuse disorder
and mental health challenges
to address their legislators and create
visibility
in the united states one in three
american households
are impacted by addiction one in three
between may 2019 and may 2020
the cdc has reported the highest record
of drug overdoses in the country
at 81 000 lives lost
the voices of nevada's recovery
community have ensured resources and
funding are focused on the communities
and services
most in need over the last few
legislative sessions
your advocacy has led to the passage of
important policies
since a good samaritan overdose law
passed in 2015
many of your organizations have worked
to train nevadans how to respond
to an overdose and have been
distributing life-saving
naloxone to naloxone kits to the
community
between february 2018 and september
2020 13 185 kits were distributed
that's more than 25 000 doses
last session your work on the ground led
to the passage of the anti-stigma bill
which amended language and state law to
remove harmful words like attic and
alcoholic
and instead use person-centered language
when referring to people with substance
use disorders
your advocacy on topics such as peer
recovery support
mental health parity and harm reduction
will continue
to move nevada in the right direction i
firmly believe that those closest to the
issue
are closest to the solution this is why
it's important that people with
lived experiences have a seat at the
table and work with experts
researchers and providers and other
professionals as
we strengthen the continuum of care in
our state
as a community we are breaking the
stigma of addiction by
sharing our stories and highlighting the
resilience of people
in recovery recovery doesn't happen in a
vacuum
it happens in our communities and must
be embedded within our schools
places of worship neighborhoods and the
workplace
that is why today i'm proud to announce
the launch of the nevada recovery
friendly
workplace initiative this is a
collaborative effort
between foundation for recovery nevada's
statewide recovery community
organization
the department of health and human
services division of welfare and social
services
and employers across the state the
initiative empowers employers to
implement recovery friendly practices
within the workplace and provide support
for people in recovery
from substance use disorder sud
as well as all those impacted recovery
friendly workplace initiative encourages
healthy and safe working environments
where employers and employees and
communities collaborate
to create positive change eliminate
stigma
and support recovery in the workplace
and in the community
the annual cost of nevada for substance
misuse
most of which is incurred by business is
6.8 billion dollars
these costs are attributed to reduction
in labor force
decreased productivity turnover
absenteeism
health care and criminal justice the
recovery friendly workplace initiative
connects employers to resources and
gives them guidance and support
from recovery friendly ambassadors as
they take steps towards
implementing recovery oriented practices
within their workplace
including free and customized staff
training
employers that join in this initiative
will receive designation as a recovery
friendly workplace
from my office this initiative
strengthens nevada's communities
by bringing those on the margins of
society into stable and productive roles
when people are able to work their
contribution impacts their families
their neighborhoods and the entire state
thank you once again for having me and
thank you all for being part of the
solution
and recovery movement in the state of
nevada i wish you all the best and
please
continue your great work you make an
enormous difference
in the lives of so many people god bless
thank you governor for that incredible
uh message and thank you for the very
exciting announcement
uh and thank you for standing up for the
recovery community here in nevada
we're grateful for your partnership and
we look forward to continuing
this important work together in the
coming months and years
i'd like to now pass the program back
over to sean o'donnell
with foundation for recovery to
introduce our next guest
who will also be presenting the
governor's proclamation
sean thank you ryan and thank you
governor sysolak
we are so excited to be launching this
new initiative with support from your
office
and our partners at the department of
public and behavioral health
and the department of welfare and social
services
you know i wish that when i was looking
for employment after treatment
these types of opportunities would have
existed i never felt comfortable being
open in the workplace about my recovery
status i'd always felt ashamed
and thought that it was something in my
past that no one needed to know about
but what if instead my recovery was
celebrated
what if that could have opened up
connections with other employees
who are currently struggling who now
felt comfortable to ask for help
we can't wait to grow this initiative
across our state and continue to work
with our early adopters
our pioneer employers who want to become
one of the first recovery-friendly
workplaces in nevada
thank you for all of your support next
we'll hear from a long-time
champion of recovery communities she has
consistently worked to bring
people with lived experience to the
table when key decisions are being made
that will affect our community time and
time again
she has shown up to listen to us and has
truly helped to foster a collaborative
working dynamic
between the state and the community
please welcome
dr stephanie woodard senior advisor on
behavioral health
at the nevada department of health and
human services dr woodard the floor is
yours
thank you and thank you sean for such a
wonderful introduction
i'm so honored to be here today
to highlight some of the important work
that's happening in the world of
recovery
here in the great state of nevada in
addition to the exciting new recovery
friendly workplace initiative that the
governor
just launched recovery support in
services
are essential assets in our communities
and within
our behavioral health system nevada
recognizes that there are many pathways
to recovery
and every individual seeking and
maintaining recovery
has a right to chart their own path free
from discrimination
with the necessary support to help them
with self-determination so that recovery
can be a process that can be supported
by others with lived experience
as such we believe that recovery
supporting policies and programs
must be available across our communities
in nevada
where people work play worship
and live through our partnerships with
recovery organizations such as
foundation for recovery
and nami nevada has been able to
integrate peer recovery supports
across our behavioral health programs
and integrate them
into the fabric of our communities i
want to just highlight a couple of these
very important programs that have
touched the lives
of thousands of individuals and is
making a difference
in saving lives every day
through the empowered and mother
programs down in southern nevada
we have peers that are working to help
pregnant and parenting moms
struggling with opioid use disorder
navigate care systems
obtain prenatal care and have safer and
healthier pregnancies
with the greatest outcome being ensuring
that those families can safely stay
together
as moms and babies move home and enter
into that postpartum period
we also have a warm line that nami has
been able to establish for us
this warm line is available to
individuals and families
who are struggling with behavioral
health issues and mental illness
that are seeking support here and now
from someone with lived experience
that again can help them navigate
through some of the challenges that they
face
stigma reduction is a very important
piece
of the work that we're doing related to
recovery and this is done
through public service announcements um
ad campaigns
online as well as offering opportunities
for individuals with lived experience
to have their voices be heard so that we
can ensure
that those individuals who are seeking
recovery and struggling with substance
use
understand that there is hope and there
is treatment and support available
we have mobile recovery outreach teams
that are going into emergency rooms
working with individuals who have
struggled with a non-fatal overdose
to help them engage and offer support
with the possibility of helping them
enter into treatment but more
importantly really focused on helping
those individuals continue to stay alive
and achieve the level of recovery that
they seek
zero suicide is another big initiative
where we're working with large hospitals
and health care systems
and this initiative is actually led by
an individual with her own lived
experience
and it is through her own voice and her
experience that she has been able to
engage over 18 large hospitals and
health care systems
in our state who have made reaching zero
suicide
a core tenant of the policies that
they're going to continue to put forward
it is also important that we do continue
to offer opportunities for
individuals in voices of recovery to
have a seat at the table
to guide us in the development of our
programs and our policies
to ensure that all decisions that are
made related to
recovery supports and treatment services
are guided
by those individuals with the experience
that can help us to better understand
what is needed
and what is desired so that we can
develop those programs and policies
with the the person who is using them in
mind
um it doesn't help if we're developing
programs and policies that really don't
resonate with the individuals that need
them the most
so ensuring that we continue to have
voices of those in recovery at the table
is a a core priority for us
i also just want to speak a little bit
about what we do also have on the
horizon
because this collaborative effort is one
that continues to grow and change
as you know there are some policies that
are being contemplated right now
uh with a lot of advocacy around them
around the certification
for peer recovery support services peers
need a pathway
to be able to enter a career where
the value that they bring with the lived
experience and the support that they can
provide
individuals who are moving through the
treatment system
is very essential in addition to that
looking at opportunities to grow and
develop recovery housing
where individuals who are actively
engaged in recovery
can live and be in safe and sober
environments with
other individuals being supported
throughout the recovery process
as we move forward we're hopeful that we
continue this very collaborative and
dynamic work
with our recovery communities as well as
all individuals that would like to join
us
in developing systems and supports that
are responsive
for individuals in recovery and with
that sean
i would like to be able to read the
governor's proclamation
yes please thank you stephanie so a
proclamation by the governor
whereas the recovery advocacy movement
is a social movement
led by people in addiction recovery and
their allies
aimed at altering public and
professional attitudes
toward addiction recovery promulgating
recovery focused
policies and programs and supporting
efforts to break
intergenerational cycles of addiction
and related problems
and whereas nevada's recovery advocates
are committed to smashing the stigma
that surrounds substance use disorder
shaping public policy and educating the
public
policy makers and service providers
about the prevalence
pathways and styles of long-term
addiction recovery
and whereas recovery advocacy
represents hope-powered community and is
about replacing
misinformation with understanding
misperception
with empathy and denial with hope
whereas major strategies of nevada's
recovery movement include
building strong grassroots recovery
community organizations
advocating for meaningful representation
and voice for people in recovery and
their families
at local and state policy levels that
affect their lives
and assessing and responding to state
and local needs
related to the advocacy and quality of
local treatment and recovery support
services
and whereas the recovery advocacy
movement
is positively altering public and
professional perceptions
of addiction recovery and forging
fundamental changes
in the design of addiction and the
nature and magnitude of recovery support
services
available to nevada citizens this
proclamation
was signed by uh steve sislak governor
of the state of nevada
declaring april 27 2021
as recovery advocacy day
thank you so much dr woodard for your
words and your continued support of our
families
and community and a huge appreciation to
governor sissellach again
for the proclamation of recovery
advocacy day 2021
today really is about smashing that
stigma
and on that note we have an incredible
group of recovery advocates joining us
today
to share some of their stories of
resilience and hope
on today's recovery stories panel we
have susie cerno a mother and tireless
recovery advocate
darcy patterson a mother woman in
recovery and founder of wake up nevada
finn tystand and alvin elliott
welcome to all of our panelists
so let's go ahead and start i just want
to go go around
and have each of you do a little
introduction
explain a little bit about what you're
doing in our state
and how you identify how you're
connected to to the recovery movement in
nevada
susie we can start with you okay good
morning everyone
well my story starts about 12 years ago
when i realized i was the mom of a son
with substance use disorder
but fear not i'm a mom and moms fix
everything and that's what i set out to
do so i did everything i could to help
my son
i thought i was helping like for example
one day he needed a shirt for work so i
left my work to help him
and i remember one night he told me he
had to pay off some guy
and if he could do that he'd be safe and
this guy wouldn't bother him anymore
so i drove him to this apartment complex
where he was to pay this guy the money
he owed him
and there i was alone in the dark and i
was so afraid that i had all crouched up
under the dashboard of my car while my
son was away
another time under the same
circumstances i drove my son to an ice
skated community
i was calmly waiting in the car when
suddenly the door flings open my son
dives into the car shouting go go go
and i drove all over the place and i
couldn't find the gate and i was too
scared to look in the rearview mirror
for fear someone was behind us
well i realized after all these
adventures i wasn't paying someone the
money
we owed them i was driving my son to
places where he could buy drugs
and my heart was broken sean and i was
sad
and my dreams for my son were gone and i
had to admit i couldn't fix this
and that's what brought me to the
recovery community
i started changing my thinking i got rid
of the stigma that caused me to be
embarrassed and ashamed
and i'm not embarrassed or ashamed
anymore and i'm not fearful of the harsh
judgment of others anymore either
i recognize now that addiction is a
disease and the fact that my son has
this disease is not my fault and i
didn't fail as a mother
so then i realized shawn that i needed a
voice
and that's when i joined recovery pac
and after that i joined recovery
advocacy
project and after that nevadans from the
common good where i started my own
addiction and recovery group
and that's kind of what brought me here
today sean i'm hoping everyone in this
group can
find their own voices and we can build a
community that puts the right supports
in place
and it's a community filled with the
help and helping and protecting people
with substance use disorders
and i'm hoping we can build a community
where everyone can become the best they
can be
thank you susie and i loved what you
said about um
you know when that that critical moment
when you realized that you didn't fail
as a mother i think that's so important
for people who are tuning in today to
hear
um i know that me personally my my
recovery journey actually started when i
was an adolescent in high school
that was the the first time that i went
to detox and treatment
and i know that my mom um and my parents
felt the same
they felt a similar way right what did
we do wrong where did we go wrong
um and they really needed to
also find that empowerment within
themselves
to understand that they they didn't do
anything wrong right that addiction is a
disease
um and that recovery is possible and
that there's hope
you know um thank you susie so much for
sharing a little bit about your story
and the work that you're doing in our
community
you're welcome darcy
yes my name is darcy patterson thank you
for having me today
i actually attended the first recovery
advocacy day
in carson city when and when we could
all be
together and it was amazing and met a
lot of wonderful people
um and i've been an advocate um
for quite a while um i really it you
know
enhanced my recovery advocacy
um when my daughter died of a heroin
overdose march 1st
2017. um i
also myself am a person in long-term
recovery
i have
six years and continue
to reach out and help others in recovery
and find sobriety and find the services
that they need in our community
one thing that i've been um really
privileged to be
a part of is wake up nevada
and that is an initiative that comes
from the reno police department
and is funded by the justice system
and we've been able to put out
information resources we have a website
we also have um we have a facebook group
that you can belong to and other
services
that you can people can reach out and
and get the the things that they needed
i
early in my daughter's um use
i really reached out to find some uh
to find some help and to find some
support and to find something that i
could
um really hold on to so that i could
help my daughter
and there
really wasn't a lot at that time so
i was um you know so i reached out and i
i found what i could find and then i
when i
you know came into recovery and my
daughter got
further into you know the recovery
habits advocacy project and other things
i i realized that these are the
resources that i needed
way back when you know she was first
using and that was the support i was
missing
and i am so thankful that today if
someone asked for that help someone
reaches out
someone needs a mom to understand
or someone who's in recovery
to you know to understand their story
that we're here for them
and there's so many people in this state
of nevada that are
pro recovery and stepping out
and doing their part to support our you
know recovery community
and be a part of what we do thank you um
for having me today
and i appreciate everybody on the panel
thank you darcy thank you for being here
and thank you for
uh being vulnerable and sharing that
part of your story and some of the work
that you're doing with
wake up nevada and a few other groups um
it's such
important work and um i i really liked
what you
had to say about reaching out and
finding help and connecting with people
that have been through similar
experiences right
and that's really what peer support is
all about that's that's the value and
that's the strength of people in
recovery
reaching out to other people in recovery
to that recovery community
and same thing with parents parents
reaching out to other parents who have
been through similar experiences and
being able to
to relate and have someone that
understands what you're going through
so thank you darcy uh finn would you
mind introducing yourself and explaining
why you stand up for recovery and a
little bit about your story
hi my name is finn tystad i'm an addict
in recovery i'm 19 years old
i attend mission high school which is a
high school that
caters to young people in recovery gives
them a platform to not only recover
but surround them with counselors other
people in recovery and other young
people
who are also attaining the same goal
which is something you can't really get
in a public high school nowadays
unfortunately i also attend apg which is
the alternative peer group
which does something similar gives all
these kids
15 16 17 18 years old a place to go
hang out have fun experiences without
the use of drugs
which has been you know wildly
successful through my life and the
people around me is life
it shows kids that you know life does
not have to
you know involve these substances in
order to have a good time
um i'm doing all of this because
as someone young so young in recovery i
almost feel like
you know the black sheep because because
nowadays especially being young
and using substances almost seems like
what you do it's what every kid does and
what they think they need to do
and it's and it's causing a lot of death
it's causing a lot of despair in these
lives so
as someone who has that experience of
going coming into recovery going to
rehab at 16 17 years old
i feel like i have a powerful voice that
kids would want to listen to me you know
you know hear something from lips of
their own you know
someone who is also young to help them
maybe get the message a little better
than someone who
they don't see as a peer so i like to
use my voice
as that
thank you fenn and i relate so much to a
little bit of the story and like the
pathway that you just described that you
went through
um i also went to treatment when i was i
think 17 16 17
for the first time and um things like
apg didn't exist you know back when i
went
and so i remember going to treatment and
then just going
right back into my same environment and
not having other people in recovery i
could connect with
and just like what you said i've oh i
felt like that black sheep
right i felt like i didn't belong i felt
weird like everyone
at in school was like that's the kid
that went to rehab right is a problem um
and so it's really awesome that you're
able to connect with
your peers other people young people in
recovery
and be able to have fun sober you know
and it's awesome that you're getting it
at such a young age you know so kudos to
you
thank you for being here uh alvin
do you want to go ahead and do a brief
intro and why you stand up for recovery
your recovery story good morning
everyone my name is alvin elliott i'm
the person in long-term recovery
and that means for me for the last 34
years
uh and in a few months 35 years i've
you know had no drugs or alcohol and i'm
grateful for
the path that i'm on in terms of my
recovery
i am a part of the recovery advocacy
project endorsement group
uh so any uh candidates on this line
that are looking to get into the
legislature
i you know help with that with anna
and others i'm also a peer recovery
specialist
uh and i'm also a facilitator for the
craft which is a community reinforcement
family training i've been an advocate
for
uh recovery for you know for the last 35
years
four years but i've been a volunteer and
an advocate
uh at the foundation for recovery for
the last
11 years since i've moved into the
valley um
from washington dc and you know i just
want to
tell you all how uh you know overwhelmed
i am at sitting here
you know a person who you know was you
know some 34 years ago
almost 35 trying to get into treatment
you know i'm sitting on a panel
with the governor of the state you know
and you know many others
you know talking about it you know you
know i want to
get back at you sean you have me come
behind the youngest person probably on
the panel
to have me close out but um yes you know
coming in to recovery my pathway to
recovery is a pathway of abstinence
you know many years of working with
groups 12-step recovery groups you know
in and around the country
uh here in nevada you know um you know i
spent the last 10 years
working at a great treatment center las
vegas recovery center
you know uh working with their alumni
group uh but also working in a community
you know um you know uh planning an
election training with track b
and chelsea uh they're doing the
outreach with anna marie
hernandez you know out on saturday and
sunday mornings
you know when the sun started to get hot
i'm thinking to myself i can't walk with
this young girl anymore
but you know um hanging hanging little
uh
signs on there you know advocating for
recovery wearing out t-shirts you know
crossing the the partisan line
okay you know um you know advocacy is a
non-partisan
issue right you know and you know it's
not a republican issue
it's not a a democratic issue it's a
human issue
right and even though you know i'm a
died in the world
a liberal from back east you know when
it comes to
uh recovery and recovery advocacy you
know i
you know i tell my friends and anyone
that will listen
that i will cross that line to vote for
someone who supports
what we support you know and i you know
and i put my
my you know my my uh actions
you know into my words into action you
know by doing that by supporting
candidates
that i may not have all the same
ideological and those
philosophical agreements with but once
it comes to legislation that goes up
to uh carson city if they're voting with
us you know people are you know in
recovery
then i'm voting with them you know and
i'm hoping
that we can continue on that line last
year was
was a great year for us you know even
though we
were in pro covert protocols we still
were
out getting out on you know on the
walkway you know
handing out literature i was a part of
the endorsement team we had you know
endorsement we were supporting
candidates
you know and that is my passion you know
uh to do those things and
continue to support you know uh the
citizens
of the of the state of nevada you know
i was listening to darcy and talking
about her uh
her daughter you know i too lost her son
you know um
he was 21 years old and
so i can i feel that you know as i look
here at finn i
i say to myself you know what would have
happened if he'd have had a
um a recovery high school to attend you
know where
you know he didn't have to feel like he
was an outcast
you know so you know he didn't have to
feel like he he was so different you
know
but my goal today is to to use that
that that that that burn that i have the
passion that i have you know uh to to
help people like him as they come along
or to help anyone that wants to come
along you know from eight to eighty
you know it doesn't matter if you're
looking to get help
uh with uh substance use disorder you
know i wanna be one of the ones on the
front of the line
you know um helping pass legislation and
getting the support that you need
you know and once again i want to i want
to thank the governor
for for his pronouncement today of
recovery friendly workplace oh my
goodness you know
the idea that a person can now go to
work without fear of losing his job
you know because i see that day in and
day out people do not want their job to
know
because they are afraid that the stigma
that surrounds
substance use disorder it will prevent
them from
you know making a living you know and
supporting their families so
um thank you all for for being here
today for this
wonderful wonderful event and thanks for
allowing me to share
thank you alvin as always
you hit everything you know perfectly
um you summarize a lot of great work
that's going on in our community and i
really wish that we had more time to
dive in because i had a whole
a lot of questions here to ask each of
you
um but we are at that time to keep
moving on in the program
um but i want to ask everyone just
before we move on
i know that this year has been
particularly difficult for a lot of
individuals what would your advice be to
anyone out there who's struggling just
as
closing remarks how have you maintained
your recovery
in your wellness over this past year
i'll start this time since i ended real
quickly
um you know there are certain practices
that i've
i've developed over the years you know
of meditation
um you know um finding um
different things to do um therapy
uh networks i mean there are more
networks now
than ever before uh finding a network
you know going you know going online to
do that
there are more people like us than we
think and people who would like to join
us
so as you as i uh scan the the you know
universe
the internet i'm looking for people who
are just like me
you know who can help support me um you
know uh as we move through this crisis
thank you all then susie
i would say something similar um i would
say to other moms find a support group
my support group really helped me
and now that we're online you can find
multiple support groups
but also there's great fulfillment
in reaching out and being involved in
other groups like recovery advocacy
project
and other other groups where you know
that you are
making a difference in helping others so
i would suggest to people to reach out
thank you susie great advice
so maintaining recovery um i think sean
you
also talked about in these hard times
with covid and one of my things was to
to realize that there were things that i
could change and what i couldn't change
and to realize that it was also a time
of grief and
to let it you know let myself grieve but
i
one of the things that helped me
immensely was
structure routine um
and reaching out to my friends that are
in recovery and
um you know joining the zoom meetings
that were available
um putting the information out about
those meetings that were available
also one thing that i do that helps me
in my recovery is
helping others with advocacy and
reducing the stigma
for those in with substance use disorder
and those who love them
i'm also involved in many mother groups
grieving groups
on facebook and that really is a huge
part of my recovery
and a huge part of my advocacy and i'm
very thankful to
that there are groups like susie said
that we can reach out to
and that um there are other moms and
dads
that can have the support um
not only when their child is possibly
out there still
using but um if they've lost them to the
substance use disorder
like i have
and for me i can say personally that an
addict alone with their own thoughts
is not a good company get connected stay
connected
find a group where you fit in that
doesn't mean it needs to be my group
or elliott's group or doctor's group but
find a group that you
fit in and you feel comfortable and stay
in stay connected and get in the middle
awesome great advice thank you
again uh for sharing your experience
with us today all of you
i really wish we had more time with each
of you and i want to take a moment
now to give special thanks to all of our
community partners who are doing just
incredible life-saving work across
nevada
we have nevadans for the common good
there is no hero in heroin
the alternative peer group in las vegas
mission high school
ridge house packed coalition
track b impact exchange nevada institute
for mental health and addiction
karma box rural nevada counseling
heart to heart and the national alliance
on mental illness nevada
including the southern northern and
western nevada affiliates
and those are just a handful of
organizations doing life-saving work in
our state and we're so appreciative
to be partnering with each of you and
working with all of you
next we will be turning our program over
to some of our
legislative experts who've been
instrumental in providing a
finger on the pulse during this session
to help us track bills
committee hearings legislative deadlines
and provide support as we move key
policies forward this year
leah tauchen and trey abney from the
abny touching group
will now give a quick legislative brief
on some of the policies
we've been tracking this session take it
away train leah
hey thanks sean again this is trey abney
the
lesser half of the abbey talcum group
and you'll hear from my business partner
leah talking here in a minute just
wanted to give a brief
um kind of lay of the land of what's
going on
with the legislature and so i'll go over
kind of the 30 000 foot view and then
leah will talk about
some of the specific bills that we've
been tracking and
advocating for on behalf of uh
of this community i mean i guess i'll
say to start that this is probably been
the weirdest
uh legislative session certainly that
we've ever been a part of
you know back you know last
late summer and fall uh governor sislak
and his team
proceeded to build a two-year budget in
the middle of a pandemic
after the bottom had fallen out of
nevada's economy and we had you know
1.30
30-something percent unemployment and uh
so you know being that their crystal
ball was very fuzzy
at that point certainly they did the
best they could
to build a budget not knowing what kind
of federal dollars
will be flowing in and that will happen
we know that a lot of federal stimulus
dollars will be coming
later we just don't know um how much
yet and so as we as we approached
february when sessions started
there was kind of this general
understanding that this was going to be
a budget session there wasn't going to
be a lot of time for
big policy issues and big policy debates
um however that uh that has proven wrong
we've had just as many bills and just as
many policy discussions as
and debates probably as a regular
session the difference is
uh until a couple weeks ago we weren't
even allowed to be inside the building
and have those conversations everything
uh like life nowadays everything has
been done
over zoom up until again just just these
last couple weeks so
where are we um for those of you that
tuned in to kind of our grassroots
uh legislative training sessions and and
updates
um you know we're obviously on a 120 day
legislative calendar 120 calendar days
uh started february 1st which means
we are now at week 13 we've got
five weeks to go until what they call
signing die which is where they gavel
gavel out for the session on may 31st
um we have been through
a couple of bill deadlines uh but to my
point earlier there were still more than
1100 bill draft requests that were
submitted
there were 935 bills
introduced which is uh pretty close to
being on track for
previous session and so we've had a lot
of stuff to follow it has not been
again the slow and and steady process
that we thought
i mentioned build deadlines because of
the 120-day calendar
again this the legislature means 120
days every other year
um they have to put deadlines in place
in order to get all their work done
we've already passed the first deadline
a few weeks back which was first
committee passage so if you're an
assembly bill you had to get out of your
first committee in the assembly
um we passed a first floor
passage uh on april 20th which means
again if you're an assembly bill you had
to get off of the assembly floor get
passed
and voted on the assembly floor and move
over the senate and uh
and vice versa now there are always
exceptions to all those rules so there
are plenty of bills that have been
exempted from those deadlines
uh because of they have a budget piece
to them or you know they're they're
worried about how much money uh
it'll cost the state but um being that
most of the bills again are stuck um on
a deadline schedule the next one
coming up on may 14th which is second
house committee passage so if you were
an assembly bill
you made it through your assembly
committee you were voted in favor off of
the assembly floor
you're now in a senate committee and you
have to get out of
that committee by may 14th and then a
week or week and a half later
of course would be your second house
passage as we get uh
rolling uh toward and then session again
as i mentioned
up until three weeks ago um we had to do
everything by zoom you would testify and
call in
by zoom my friend sean o'donnell knows
that
very well having had to do that several
times now we appreciate his hard work
on advocating on behalf of the recovery
community
uh we can now enter the building but you
have to show a vaccination card you have
to or
get get a vaccination before you walk in
or get a test before you walk in and so
it's still very limited each legislator
can only have one person per day
come visit them which really limits the
ability for folks to
to come and visit so that's just kind of
a lay of the land i will hand it over to
uh
leah for the smart stuff and she'll tell
you us about some specific bills that
we've been following for you
leah go ahead good morning thank you so
much for joining us
we just wanted to take an opportunity to
discuss some of the recovery friendly
legislation that we've seen this session
and i will tell you uh train i've been
fortunate enough to work with the
recovery advocacy project
and foundation for recovery for the last
two sessions
and just watching um the number of
recovery friendly bills grow each
session
uh is just a testament to what all of
you are you know the importance of the
work that you're all doing and the time
that you're spending with us today
and um so trey mentioned the deadline
that we just passed
we've got a couple of bills that um are
important to us that are at the prior on
the priority list of our
bill tracker and um one of them being
assembly bill 374 which is jill tolle's
bill
to create a statewide substance use
response working group and this one is
just so important because two sessions
ago we saw the creation of the regional
behavioral health policy boards and
um the important work that's being done
there where they're driving
bills that are behavioral health related
a lot of times have components to
substance use
and um so now we're seeing this session
another group
uh this statewide substance use response
working group
that will incorporate as you heard dr
woodard and governor syslex
talk about um tapping in to that
lived experience and having advocates at
the table
sharing their story and um
and also it keeps the momentum when
we're not in session to have these
groups that are going to work
all year round every year whether we're
in session or not
and in this bill specifically why it's
so
important is it's a 16 member board
being created
and there are a number of positions
um on that board that will be
those voices that we are the lived
experience voice at the table
and so we're just so excited to see that
that is being considered and that the
legislators are incorporating that
into legislation that it's at the top of
their mind
and um so in this bill specifically it
calls out that there will be an
advocate for persons who have substance
use disorders and family members of such
persons
it calls out a person who is in recovery
from a substance use disorder it it
incorporates a person who provides
services related to the treatment of
substance use disorder
so you can see where i'm going with this
example it just it draws
this coalition in to these conversations
and
again we're going to be having them year
round so that bill passed
unanimously out of the assembly and we
have no doubt it will pass unanimously
out of the senate
and be signed by the governor
additionally another bill just to call
to your attention is assembly bill 158
this is assemblywoman monroe moreno's
bill to revise the penalties for persons
who are under 21 years of age
and have been found for first-time
offenses been found in possession of
alcohol or cannabis
and so we're just seeing again a
refocusing and a shifting
um you know not looking at jail time but
looking at treatment
looking at other alternatives and and
helping to set those individuals on a
different track
we have a handful i know we're short on
time today
we'd love to dive deep into all of these
bills but we have a handful
um of other bills that are um
also moving forward in the process uh
sb senate bill 69 which is the
um washoe regional behavioral health
policy boards bill to certify a person
who
um is providing or supervising peer
recovery
support services that uh that bill
foundation for recovering recovery
advocacy project have been so
just integrated in since the beginning
and have have moved the ball forward on
that where
we've got uh that bill the policy has
already been approved
now it's in it what's called a money
committee and
that is just um any bill
that has any financial component to it
after the policy is approved it has to
go through that committee and so that's
where
that bill sits now another bill that
sits in a money committee is assembly
bill 370
that's assemblywoman dickman's bill on
allocating some of the liquor tax
revenue
for recovery services so we're seeing
again just some of that money diverted
from the general fund
specific to recovery services
um and then we've also got um i'm sure
many of you have seen in the news
some of the opioid litigation uh
that have uh infused some money into the
attorney general's office
after having uh battled some of those
pharmaceutical companies 45 million
dollars is one of the latest settlements
so senate bill 390 is senator ratty's
bill
that will focus on the administration of
that uh
that opioid litigation funding and
um and her bill also will uh use part of
that for the creation of a statewide
behavioral health
crisis hotline so that bill also sitting
in a money
committee as you can imagine but um
we will be providing to anna maria and
the rest of the team
a recovery update that you'll see or
sorry recovery
friendly legislative update that you'll
see um
sent out probably later in the week and
we'll have links to all the bills so you
can
dive in as deep as you want you can read
them and we are always
happy and available to um answer
questions and
just help walk anyone that's interested
through the process so you can
see where we are because as trey said
120 days
goes by very quickly and if it weren't
for these deadlines it would be pretty
hard to keep everybody on track
so thank you so much for your time this
morning it's really exciting to be here
and share this information with you
thank you leah and um thanks to
everybody uh
who's with us i i just have to call out
because i think it's phenomenal we are
just
we are right on time i mean it's always
great when we stay completely on time
and tick tock anybody who knows me just
i love being on time so we're still on
time with this schedule which is
uh phenomenal you know as you can all
see the work that we've been engaged in
as a recovery community is really
beginning to pay off
we're excited to see so many of these
legislative initiatives
inch closer to the finish line and we're
grateful for all the support
uh from this community that has gotten
us the recovery community this far
i'd encourage all of you to continue to
stay engaged as we still have a lot more
work to do
and we need all the help we can get at
the end of today's
advocacy day we'll provide some
information on how you can stay involved
in ways
that you can keep up with these
legislative initiatives as they
work their way through carson city i now
have
the honor of introducing our first
legislators
who are joining us this morning some of
them have been able to join us live
some of them uh because we're in the
middle of session and they're going back
and forth from committee meetings
uh some have also provided some video
messages
uh i i think it goes without saying that
without them
many of these great pieces of
legislation uh
would have not been possible this
session so
we'll go ahead and kick it off uh with
our first
um member of the senate who's joining us
live
and that's senator joe hardy senator
hardy are you there
i am not only here i can hear you loud
and clear
wonderful welcome to recovery advocacy
day
thank you you'll you'll notice i've got
a virtual screen
going on in the background of what it
looks like
when you've been
on something and you wish you weren't
anymore
so would you like me to say something
yes sir the floor is yours okay so um
you know i've been involved with uh this
concept of recovery for some time
probably all my medical career and
so i've i've thought about recovery and
how it happens
and recovery actually
happens by degrees and if you look
consider the math of
geometry recovery
once you're in a position where you need
to recover
you go in degrees and so the recovery
starts with a 45 degree
change where you stop you withdraw you
avoid
and you hear the common uh
phrase of 28 days it takes in a recovery
mode so that 28 days is the 45
degrees and then you go into a re
rehabilitation phase
which is a 90 degrees and the 90 degrees
is kind of like muscle memory
you you start doing what you learned
to do and then you just go and do that
and you go slow and you've heard the
concept of 90 meetings in 90 days
so it's a 90 degree concept
and then you go into the next phase i
would call it
the return and the return is about 135
degrees
and that's when you you're converted
you say okay i'm doing this well
and i need to help others and that's you
know a six to 12 month
period of time where you you realize you
do care and you are converted and you
are changing
and you've changed and then you you come
to a point where i called
the resume resume your life and you're
at 180 degrees and some people call them
but
talk about 360 degrees i don't want
anybody to go back
a hundred and or 360 degrees because
then you're back where you started
with recovery or with
a problem so you need to resume at 180
days
180 degrees rather
and then you just do life except you do
it better than you've ever done before
when you've recovered
at 180 degrees you're going further
along than you ever were before you've
learned
something you've never learned before
and so you've resumed life
in a better way and it's 180 degrees
going forward instead of going backwards
360.
and then i thought okay so how do you do
it you have
tools that we use from a medical
standpoint for a
mental health standpoint tools such as
medicines like naloxone naltrexone
buprenorphine methadone those are all in
different degrees
and then you have people have friends
you have family of doctors you have
bosses you have the law and then you
have
programs that are available 12
program service oriented uh things and
you have
been a sponsor yourself uh to and then
ultimately in this 180 degree
change you ultimately you have
your higher power you have forgiveness
you learn to forgive yourself
and forgive others and in your process
of forgiving others
you've learned to forgive yourself which
is probably harder than anything else
so as i look at it that's the recovery
process
and that's what we do and how we do it
and then we help others along that road
and that's my simple talk for the day
and open for any questions or
teach me something because i always like
to learn
something okay ryan back to you thank
you
thank you senator hardy thank you so
much for your support of this community
and we
uh look forward to continuing to work
with you and uh thank you for for your
talk on degrees i
i i found that uh very enlightening
myself um
we are going to uh shift to our our next
legislators because we're waiting for
some more to come in
we do have some um pre-recorded messages
uh from legislators who were unable to
join us live this morning and we'll go
ahead and start
uh with senator julia ratty first
um if we could go ahead and there we go
senator ratty hello everyone and welcome
to recovery advocacy day
i so very wish that you could be here
with me in carson city and that we would
be all spending this time together
but i am just so proud of the work
that's been done on recovery issues by
advocates like you
even during the pandemic when we're
using all different kinds of tools to
get the word out to legislators in this
building and i just want to let you know
that i appreciate you very much
thanks to so many who leaned in to
support senate bill 69 that i've been
working on with the washoe county
regional behavioral health board
we hope that that policy to do some more
in terms of substance use disorder
prevention
and to build our pure uh workforce
is going to be a good policy that makes
it to the end so again thank you for
that
and of course we'll do everything we can
to keep recovery in mind as we're
working on other
behavioral health bills that go through
the session so again thanks for staying
engaged and i hope you have a great
recovery advocacy day
i appreciate you all thank you
thank you senator ratty and uh we do
have another legislator who's just
joined us live uh
i'd like to introduce her she's done a
lot for us this session and has some
great legislation
moving forward assemblywoman jill
dickman are you
with us i am how are you all today
good to see you the floor is yours
assemblywoman good to see you too
well thanks for um letting me interrupt
your event today to speak to you for a
minute
um we're all here because we know how
important recovery support services are
for the people who need the most
we have to do everything we can to make
sure that the recovery journey doesn't
end at the door of a treatment facility
i know that your priority um as it has
been one of my priorities this session
as well
and i want to thank you all for your
work and your passion for helping um our
fellow nevadans
as some of you may know i sponsored
assembly bill 370 this session
which would allocate money um to
dpph for community providers to offer
more of these important services
unfortunately through the legislative
process the bill has been amended and
the amount of funding
significantly cut but it's my hope that
we can still get the bill passed
so we can establish this program at dpbh
and show the legislature that that these
programs and services
work not only for the people who need
help but also to save our state money
in our underfunded behavioral health
systems
so thank you all again for your time and
for your work
um i hope you have a great meeting
and enjoy your day i wish you could be
here in person
because we'd like to see all of you well
thank you assemblywoman and we can't
we can't wait to be back in person as
well and as soon as we're able to we
will be back up there
uh in carson city and thank you for all
the work and for standing uh with the
recovery community and
just being a tireless advocate for us
we're we are incredibly
uh grateful our next uh legislator
who is super busy and uh many of you
know him he's he's done a lot of work
with foundation for recovery and the
recovery advocacy project and has been a
great advocate for our issues his
assembly member steve yeager
uh who offered a video if we could go
ahead and
roll assemblyman yeager
good morning everyone i'm assemblyman
steve yeager
and i'd like to welcome you to recovery
day at the nevada legislature
i wish we could all be here together in
person but obviously the world had
different plans in store for us
but the hard work continues and i want
to thank you for
all of your work on behalf of the
recovery community
please know that we are also working
hard at the legislature
to treat this issue for what it is
a mental and behavioral health issue
we're working hard to make sure that
offenders get appropriate treatment
they don't need to be in the criminal
justice system they need treatment
and that includes our minor offenders
we're working on lessening penalties
and getting them help i'm confident that
with your help
we're going to get this right as we
continue to move forward this
legislative session
so again from the bottom of my heart
thank you so very much
and have a great recovery advocacy day
at the nevada legislature
thank you assembly member jaeger and
before we go to our next panel we have
one more message
dr assembly member dr uh robin titus
good morning i'm dr roman titus and i
serve as the assembly republican leader
in the legislature as a 37-year
career family practice doctor i
particularly want to thank you for
participating and wanted to virtually
wish you a welcome
to recovery advocacy day i wish that we
could be
in person in carson city but
unfortunately we've all become quite
good at zoom over the past year
i would like to thank everyone for your
interest in advancing recovery friendly
policy
i recently participated in the dea's
national prescription drug
take back day because i know too often
substance misuse begins in the home
medicine cabinet
i will continue to keep the recovery
community in mind
when it comes to your continued work on
behavioral health issues
thank you and stay strong thank you dr
titus and now i'd like to
uh pass the virtual stage uh back to
sean
o'donnell uh for our next panel which
i'm really looking forward to
on recovery resources in our state sean
thank you ryan oh my gosh it was so
awesome to hear from
all of those legislators who joined us
to share some messages about
uh the work that we've done as advocates
um this session and in previous sessions
so
um really really awesome to hear from
all of you thank you so much
so now we'll be jumping into our
recovery um in our community
panel and as ryan had mentioned um we
are joined by
not only advocates but by different
providers in our state
who are doing incredible work on the
ground to help
uh you know turn the needle just a
little bit more in the right direction
when it comes to recovery and support
services so today we have cindy farns
she is a peer recovery support
specialist at foundation for recovery
chelsea cheatham from track b impact
exchange bob vickery from the pact
coalition
john newell the project director of the
building communities of recovery program
and he is also a peer recovery support
specialist at foundation for recovery
and we have walter sanders from rural
nevada counseling
so welcome everyone uh thank you for
being here today
so let's go ahead and just hop right in
i have a few questions that i want to
open up to the full panel
um would each of you mind going around
and sharing a little bit about your
organization's work and what you do in
the community
and bob we could go ahead and start with
you
hello everybody thank you sean so much
my name is bob victory uh
and as mentioned i am a project
coordinator with pact coalition i'm also
a person in long-term recovery and
i wish i had all the time in the world
to express the gratitude and hope that i
have heard here today it is just
incredibly it has infused me with just
incredible energy to do this good work
and i thank everybody
uh so for those of you many of us uh
participants and stakeholders of packed
coalition are on the call today
so i'll do my best to be brief about who
uh we are in the community
but we are um a coalition for a safe
and drug-free community and we're a
non-profit 501c3
and i think the most important thing i
can say about pac is that i've
discovered since i've been
on the team is that we bring community
organizations
leadership um agencies
together to strengthen the community by
acting as a neutral convening table and
that's a
a term that jamie ross has you know
impressed upon me our executive director
so when i'm out representing the
community it was mentioned
we are nonpartisan we bring together
over 70
organizations and agencies together
around the table every month
we used to do it in person we hope to do
it soon
and uh we work to address emergent
issues around substance misuse
by offering resources of prevention
we're a pass-through agency for federal
and state funding
and our work is to get these resources
out to the agencies that are boots on
the ground
doing the good work in the community to
try to reduce
all of the things that we talked about
today not only the
uh our opioid epidemic that's claiming
so many lives
to try to reduce death and overdose
in injury but also to try to
remove stigma in our community and
increase
language so that uh folks understand
the significance of the work that we
need to do in the community so
i'm very proud to be part of pac and i'm
very proud to be part
of our discussion today thank you
thank you bob and thank you to the pac
coalition for really helping be that
connector in our community and bringing
multiple organizations together to
address this issue
in our community next chelsea cheetham
do you want to explain a little bit
about track b and what you guys do
yes hi everyone my name is chelsea
cheatham and i work at track b
exchange thank you very much for having
me as a part of this panel today
um track be exchange is a harm reduction
program so harm reduction is when you
reduce
your risk of a negative consequence for
something that someone is doing so
in our program we're a syringe exchange
and we're the only syringe exchange here
in southern nevada currently
and we provide people with a stigma free
supportive environment
for people who use substances to get the
supplies they need in order to stay
healthy
we want to provide people with education
and tools and a place to seek help
and to ask for treatment when they're
ready
i also co-chair the southern nevada harm
reduction alliance which is a great
group of people
and organizations many of whom are on
this call today
um and we're a group of harm reduction
groups treatment providers recovery
organizations
people that are also in recovery as well
as allies and we're all working together
to meet people where they're at
in their lives including their journey
to treatment and recovery
and we do that by taking information and
services to people exactly where they
are
thank you chelsea um yeah and i love
that you have brought up the southern
nevada home reduction alliance as well i
think that we've sort of heard this
resounding theme from other people alvin
had talked about this been and talked
about this
and so it's susie about getting involved
right and getting active and
participating in some of these groups
that are meeting and
kind of find your niche and and where
you want to belong and and
doing some valuable work and the
southern nevada harm reduction alliance
um
is just another uh group that anyone can
participate in
if you're interested in harm reduction
right and getting that information out
to communities
so thank you chelsea cindy do you want
to go next
hello everyone i'm cindy and i am a peer
support specialist
and person in long-term recovery i
currently am working with the awesome
organization foundation for recovery
and super excited to be a part of
this advocacy day it's been mentioned a
lot about having a voice
through different participants in this
format and
i think it's just it's super important
because by us
sharing from our experience and strength
and hope with other people in recovery
like we give them the courage to do the
same and
substance use disorder and mental health
struggles they do not discriminate
so i think that it's important to
realize like it's this is a complex
issue
you know but it's also a human issue and
there's so many different pathways
through recovery
and um the foundation for recovery
supports
many of those pathways and working as a
peer support specialist
um i think it's important to um the
bills that are being passed as far as
having um having a credential like
holding us accountable making us
sustainable in the community because
there is a gift in that lived experience
you know where we can help bridge gaps
especially out in like rural nevada
um where there are the need for more
resources
we can kind of be out in those
communities and we can help give those
people a voice
and help to bridge gaps in you know in
in hopes of establishing more of a
continuum and not just helping the
person recover but helping our
communities to recover as a whole
from you know the issues that are
created by substance use disorder
removing the stigma i'm
giving you know giving people the
resources coping skills tools
um all the different things you know so
we as peer support specialists work in
a non-clinical setting but we are
perfect for that gap between that human
being
and the clinical and what happens in
between and helping to connect all the
dots so
i'm just super grateful to be part of
this solution to be part of such a group
of amazing individuals and thank you for
all using your voice to make a
difference
you know i can't but we can so thank you
thank you cindy um we're so glad that
you're here today
and i'm so grateful that you are a
member of our team
i know that you're doing great work out
in rural communities where you
travel on a weekly basis to go offer
things like peer recovery support
different all recovery meetings recovery
yoga
naloxone trainings out into these
communities and i love what you said
about how we can help bridge that gap
right between
the human and maybe higher levels of
care
and that's really the point behind like
indigenous organic recovery support
services
is that it's inherently low barrier
right we know that
in almost every single community people
like us
exist and giving them the tools to be
able to share freely with other people
who might be struggling
how to find and access support is so
so valuable so thank you for for your
words
um walter do you want to go ahead and
introduce yourself and your organization
sure my name is walter saunders i work
for role in nevada counseling
um i'm a licensed social worker licensed
alcohol and drug counselor and a mental
health therapist
and uh we're out here in lion
lyon county nevada which is one of the
largest geographical rural areas
in nevada i think we're probably about
100 square miles or something like that
and we have four offices out here
and i live in reno so i traveled the
last six years out to
rural um pretty much every day um
and we are one of about a dozen
what the state now calls behavioral
health centers
in nevada which is a a newer concept
it's still in its
early days but it's a new concept from
samsha which is the federal
you know substance abuse mental health
services agency
um and it's uh it's amazing um
[Music]
you know as mentioned uh earlier one of
the biggest
challenges we have in the rural
community is access to services
and um it's even more pronounced in the
rural community because
you know reno in las vegas if somebody
seeking recovery
they can kind of jump on a bus or a bike
and go somewhere and that's not quite
the case
when your your area is about 100 square
miles
you know and so um the behavioral health
center uh
is also a bit different um for those
that are in long-term recovery from
many years ago treatment providers tend
to be siloed back then
mental health over here substance over
here targeted case management over here
and of course every over here is another
place that a person seeking recovery
falls off
because they don't make their
appointments or you know they just get
burned out and they don't want to return
the behavioral health centers allowed us
to put everything under one roof so we
have medication prescribers we have a
medication a medicaid assisted treatment
provider on staff for
you know methadone suboxone subutex
vivitrol
psychiatric medications if needed every
week
of course one of the exciting things
that we do is we have peers
i believe i now have 18 or 16 or 18
peers on staff
um they drive the vans out to clients
houses take them to appointments
you know just really engaging that role
peer support specialist
a peer recovery specialist is so
critical
um they're that bridge between you know
the the counselor and
and the therapist and that person in
early recovery
uh that that that motivation that
support and um
we also provide uh two transitional
living homes out here and rule
in rural nevada uh previously uh
you know when an addict needed these
types of services we kind of sent them
to las vegas to reno because they had
more resources
but really that's a punishment to the
attic seeking recovery right
we're taking you out of your community
out of your job and we're going to send
you to another town
even though the treatment provider had
the greatest intent which was to connect
them the resources
it could be viewed as punishment it
disrupted families and
so having these homes in the community
in which these
you know clients reside has been you
know a game changer
uh and so yeah we're just hoping that um
these behavioral health centers will
catch on
uh they give us a lot more resources and
and it also gives us the ability you
know previously you went to treatment
here's the curriculum we do this for
everybody and that's the way it is and
as it's been stressed on this call by
many people including dr woodard
uh every path is a different path and so
you
you kind of have to be able to give the
providers the ability
to meet the clients where they're at and
come up with their own individualized
paths and these behavioral health
centers really allow us to do that with
case management and peer and basic
skills training and a lot of those
things that we do so
that's kind of what we do here in lyon
county
awesome thank you walter a lot of great
work along that whole continuum
it sounds like of care um out in the
rural communities
um and i i will say that we are coming
up on time these panels go really
quickly uh so we'll keep moving on with
program but i will uh
introduce um john newell as well um john
do you want to go ahead and introduce
yourself and some of the work that
you're doing out in
communities absolutely my name is john
newell and i'm a person in long-term
recovery and what that means
for me is that i've been drug and
alcohol free for over 19 years
uh there's not really a lot that i
need to add to everything
that's went forth already sean i'm
looking at you
it's been my experience that my
internet connection is a little
unsustainable here
i'm actually so if i do freeze give me
some jazz hands or something
just got a message that it's unstable
but uh so i'm
actually currently in hawthorne nevada
right now
working in a satellite location where my
internet is a little unstable get it
and uh cindy pretty
much summed up everything uh what i
will add is that uh through the
initiative that we are working on
b core which stands for building
communities of
recovery like our intention
and our focus is to bring
into rural and frontier counties
throughout the state of nevada
where there's already a limited
amount of services we're just here to
add to the menu we're here to plug
in gaps and fill in holes wherever there
are things that are like
all of the free services that we provide
and i will say you guys
this particular location that i'm
working out of today in hawthorne nevada
is very near and dear to my heart and
it's a
honor and a privilege that i get to
travel here every other week so
for the second time sean i'm gonna wrap
up there and
give it back to you thank you john sean
are you there
yes yes thank you so much um for
explaining a little bit about what
you're doing
um cindy's actually on that b core team
as well um and one one thing i'll just
say that
our experience has been going into rural
communities and working
with rural communities adding to that
menu of services as john invention
is um faith-based organizations have
really opened up their doors and been
welcoming um to be able to provide space
in the community um and work with us and
that has just been an incredible
experience
um and it goes back to what uh you know
it really echoes what dr woodard had
said what the governor has said
i had said in opening remarks as far as
making these services a part of our
everyday environments
right that someone doesn't need to
necessarily go to a separate spot to
access these services
but they exist where they work live and
play right um
so i i will say thank you all again for
being
on today's panel um and for this great
discussion
i'm sorry but we have to move on and
again i had over planned with like 10
other questions to ask everyone
um and i really wish we would have got
there but maybe at another time we can
we can hop on and do this again